autodenominado como absolutista de la
libertad de expresión en los modos
prometió reforzar la Libertad en el
flujo de la información a través de
Twitter cuando compró la plataforma pero
recientemente suspendió las cuentas de
media docena de periodistas Sin dar
ninguna explicación
mosc recurrió a Twitter luego de la
suspensiones para acusar a los
periodistas de compartir información
privada acerca de su paradero que
describió como básicamente coordenadas
de asesinato como es el caso de la
cuenta elonjet que había acumulado más
de medio millón de Seguidores y se
dedicaba a rastrear el uso de los
aviones privados del Magnate
estadounidense Desatando la ira de Moss
durante mucho tiempo hace un mes el
multimillonario de la tecnología Se
comprometió a permitir que siguiera
funcionando aunque fuera un riesgo
directo para su seguridad personal según
los informes el estudiante universitario
detrás de la cuenta Jack sweeney había
rechazado su oferta de 5000 dólares para
eliminarla Por otra parte la cuenta de
mandon que ha surgido como una
alternativa
desde la toma de control de mosc también
fue suspendida sin explicación el
comisionado de valores y transparencia
de la Unión Europea twiteó que la
suspensión arbitraria de periodistas era
preocupante y recordamos el respeto a la
libertad de prensa y los derechos
fundamentales
mosc ha realizado cambios importantes en
la moderación de contenido en Twitter
desde que tomó control y ha restablecido
cuentas de alto perfil como la de Donald
Trump quien previamente rompió las
reglas de Twitter contra conductas de
odio o desinformación pero también ha
dicho que suprimiría la negatividad y el
odio al privar algunas cuentas de la
libertad de